[Music]
all animals communicate crabs wave their
claws at each other to signal that
they're healthy and ready to mate
cuttlefish use pigmented skin cells
called chromatophores to create patterns
on their skin that act as camouflage or
warnings to rivals honeybees perform
complex dances to let other bees know
the location and quality of a food
source all of these animals have
impressive communication systems but do
they have language to answer that
question we can look at four specific
qualities that are often associated with
language discreteness grammar
productivity and displacement
discreteness means that there is a set
of individual units such as sounds or
words that can be combined to
communicate new ideas like a set of
refrigerator poetry magnets you can
rearrange to create different phrases
grammar provides a system of rules that
tells you how to combine those
individual units productivity is the
ability to use language to create an
infinite number of messages and
displacement is the ability to talk
about things that are right in front of
you such as past future or fictional
events
does animal communication exhibit any of
these qualities for crabs and cuttlefish
the answer is no they don't combine
their signals in creative ways those
signals also don't have to be in a
grammatical order and they only
communicate current conditions like I am
healthy or I am poisonous but some
animals actually do display some of
these properties bees use the moves
angle duration and intensity of their
waggle dance to describe the location
and richness of a food source that
source is outside the hive so they
exhibit the property of displacement
they share that language trait with
prairie dogs which live in towns of
thousands and are hunted by coyotes
hawks badgers snakes and humans their
alarm calls indicate the Predators size
shape speed and even for human predators
what the person is wearing and if he's
carrying a gun great apes like chimps
and gorillas are great communicators too
some have even learned a modified sign
language a chimpanzee named Washoe
demonstrated discreteness by combining
multiple signs into original phrases
like please open hurry Koko a female
gorilla who understands more than 1,000
signs and around 2,000 words of spoken
English referred to a beloved kitten
that had died in doing so she displayed
displacement though it's worth noting
that the Apes in both of these examples
were using a human communication system
not one that appeared naturally in the
wild there are many other examples of
sophisticated animal communication such
as in dolphins which use whistles to
identify age location names and gender
they can also understand some grammar in
a gestural language researchers use to
communicate with them
however grammar is not seen in the
dolphins natural communication while
these communication systems may have
some of the qualities of language we've
identified none display all four even
Washoe and Koko
impressive abilities are still outpaced
by the language skills of most
three-year-old humans and animals topics
of conversation are usually limited bees
talk about food prairie dogs talk about
predators and crabs talk about
themselves human language stands alone
due to the powerful combination of
grammar and productivity on top of
discreteness and displacement the human
brain can take a finite number of
elements and create an infinite number
of messages we can craft and understand
complex sentences as well as words that
have never been spoken before we can use
language to communicate about an endless
range of subjects talk about imaginary
things and even lie research continues
to reveal more and more about animal
communication it may turn out that human
language and animal communication aren't
entirely different but exist on a
continuum after all we are all animals
you
[Music]